how should biden have reacted to that
inflation joke that's what people are
going to ask they're going to say oh
michael lighten up come on what was he
going to do yes it's a bad look for a
joke about record high inflation record
high gas prices record high food prices
things that are really hurting a lot of
americans it's a bad look for biden to
laugh at that but what was he going to
do
there's actually an answer to this
it's true had joe biden frowned and
grimaced and gotten really angry
that wouldn't have worked that would not
have landed either had he pulled a will
smith and gone up and smacked trevor now
in the face that probably wouldn't have
worked either but likewise he he also
shouldn't have just laughed and gaffawed
and bellied over and clapped his hands
that wasn't a good look either what he
could have done
is is the sort of thing in a in a roast
even or when someone tells an off-color
joke that you don't want to laugh at you
don't want to ascent to but you don't
want to seem like a stick in the mud you
kind of say hey come on
you know you put a little a little bit
of a smile on your face but you say
that's too far hey come on buddy put
your finger out there
a younger joe biden would have gotten
this the reason i'm even focusing on his
reaction here is not because it shows
joe biden to be some evil kind of genius
or any kind of genius he's certainly
never been that it's to show you how
much he's lost of his old political
instinct joe biden of
20 years ago 10 years ago even five
years ago would never have made that
mistake that clip of him laughing at
inflation and laughing at gas prices
going up and laughing at his terrible
economy that's going to be in every
republican campaign ad from now until
november
okay that is going to be plastered
across the airwaves it was a political
misstep joe biden when he had his
marbles or
at least some of his marbles he wouldn't
have fallen into that trap he would have
had a much better political gut
but he he's lost that he we played a
clip last last week on the show now joe
biden blames his senility his obvious
senility on the re-emergence of a
childhood stutter
well look at a clip of him
5 10 20 years ago he didn't have that
stutter i'm not saying he was a rhodes
scholar but the fella could speak
he knew how to read a political scene he
knew how to read a room and slap him
back and smile that that was his
political skill he didn't have that it
was really ugly it did not look good
at the white house correspondents dinner
biden then gets up and reads his jokes
himself the presidents generally do
pretty well at the white house
correspondents association dinner
because they hire hollywood comedy
writers to write all the jokes for them
so biden gets up and his his sharpest
joke of the night was a joke about the
difference between the modern republican
party and the party of ronald reagan
but i'm not worried about the midterms
i'm not worried about them we may end up
with more partisan gridlock but i'm
confident we can work it out during my
remaining six years of the presidency
i'm not really here to roast the gop
that's not my style besides there's
nothing i can say about the gop that
kevin mccarthy hasn't already put on
tape
at the same
at the same time a lot of people say the
republican party is too extreme too
divisive too controlled by one person
they say it's not your father's
republican party
ronald reagan said mr gorbachev tear
this wall down
today's republicans say tear down mickey
mouse's house
and pretty soon they'll be storming
cinderella's castle you can be sure of
it
republicans
seem to support one fellow
some guy named brandon
he's having a really good year
and i'm kind of happy for him
delivery is not what it once was not
exactly don rickles up there but you get
the joke the joke and he didn't even get
the line right by the way it's probably
four of the most famous words in
american history tear down this wall
bit mr gorbachev tear down this wall and
and biden couldn't even remember that
though he was in the united states
senate at the time but he says okay the
the old gop said
mr gorbachev tear this wall down and the
modern gop says tear down cinderella's
castle
but
even that joke underscores a big
political weakness for democrats right
now yes during the cold war the
conservatives were unified focusing on
problems overseas because you had a
threat from the soviet union
you had the threat of the cold war
once the berlin wall fell down
then there was a cold war that was being
waged not around the globe but a cold
cultural war that was being raged at
home
that has become hot on many occasions
why is it that modern-day republicans
are saying mr disney tear down
cinderella's castle because the walt
disney corporation is trying to trans
little kids it's not just disney that's
supporting this it's pretty much every
corporation and its teachers all the way
down to kindergarten and preschool who
are now insistent with the support of
elected democrats up to and including
joe biden up to and including all of the
white house agencies saying it is
essential health care it is it is so
important for five-year-olds to be put
on puberty blockers cross-sex hormones
potentially have their bodies mutilated
if little boys think they're little
girls that's that's the joke
these modern republicans
they don't even think we should chop off
five-year-olds genitals
uh yeah
and the white house correspondents
association they're all laughing because
they're all pro
mutilate little kids bodies they're all
pro put little boys on cross-sex
hormones and little girls on
testosterone
they're all in favor of that and they
don't realize
how
completely out of touch they are with
the rest of america not just with
republicans not just with conservatives
but with parents everywhere all around
the country they don't even get it if
you want to be able to
tell jokes
you need to have some
connection to the common sense
you need
you need the things that you're saying
to resonate with people
ordinary common people not just whacked
out liberals who think that it's a good
idea to transgender five-year-olds and
they have lost that common sense and
this is not my own wish casting this is
not my own ideological view of things
i'm just one looking at common sense two
looking at tradition and three looking
at the poll numbers there's a marist
poll that just came out
of voting preferences among parents of
kids under 18.
so when you loses a poll of 1300
national registered voters that just
took place a couple of weeks ago
when you look at just
voters who have children under the age
of 18 they are twice as likely to vote
for republicans as for democrats
that so please joe keep telling that
joke bring it on
because the joke ultimately is going to
be on you it's going to be on the
democrats it's going to be on the white
house correspondents association and
biden and big tech and the media and the
whole thing
it's just all the liberal blob
now maybe they rigged the election and
it wouldn't wouldn't be the first time
but absent some true shenanigans absent
some
suspension of the ordinary election
rules and getting rid of the poll
watchers and changing the violating the
state constitution certain places absent
that kind of
active rigging of the election right now
if you look at the poll numbers and you
look at the way that the democrats are
campaigning including in their jokes
including all the way up to joe biden
the democrats are in for a tsunami
come
november i'm glad you like that clip now
ding ding ding ring that bell subscribe
get all the notifications for all of our
videos you can also head over to the
michael knowles show on apple podcast
spotify stitcher wherever you listen to
your audio podcasts subscribe get it
you'll thank me later leave a five star
review if you don't mind we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]